>> Sean: WE HAVE THE
TRANSCRIPT THAT THE UKRAINE ON
WHISTLE-BLOWER WHISTLE-BLOWER
HEARSAY WHISTLE-BLOWER HOAX
CONTINUES.
TODAY A WHITE HOUSE OFFICIAL
ALEXANDER GOODMAN TESTIFIED
BEHIND CLOSED DOORS ABOUT HIS
UKRAINE CALL CONCERNS AND
PRESIDENT TRUMP LASTED HIM AS
ANOTHER TRUMP WITNESS.
NOW HE WITH REACTION,
SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM HAD TO BE
A DEMOCRAT TODAY, THIS IS THE
DEPTH OF BLIND RAGE OF PSYCHOSIS
AND HYPOCRISY.
THINK ABOUT THIS.
YOU HAVE TO BE OKAY WITH HILLARY
STEALING THE PRIMARY FROM
BERNIE, YOU HAVE TO ACCEPT THAT
SHE VIOLATED THE ESPIONAGE ACT.
YOU HAVE TO ACCEPT THAT WHAT SHE
DID WITH DELETING EMAILS AND
DELETIONS IS OKAY, YOU HAVE TO
ACCEPT THAT SHE DID HAVE A DIRTY
RUSSIAN DOSSIER SHE TRIED TO
USE.
YOU HAVE TO ACCEPT THAT IT WAS
OKAY TO USE THE UNVERIFIED
DOSSIER EVEN THOUGH YOU WARNED
FIVE TIMES TO GET A WARRANT WHEN
IT'S UNVERIFIABLE AND WHY ON THE
FLY'S APPLICATIONS.
YOU HAVE TO ACCEPT THE
OUTSOURCING OF INTELLIGENCE
GATHERING.
YOU HAVE TO ACCEPT THAT UKRAINE
HAS ALLOWED TO INTERFERE TO HELP
HER AND IT SORT OF BIG DEAL THAT
IF THAT'S HOW INSANE THIS NOW
IS.
IF YOU'RE A DEMOCRAT.
>> IT'S EVEN DEEPER.
YOU HAVE TO ACCEPT THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS PRESIDENT.
THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
THEY DON'T ACCEPT THE
PRESIDENT TRUMP WON THE ELECTION
AND AMERICA HATES A SORE LOSER
IS MUCH AS ANY COUNTRY ON THE
PLANET.
THIS IS AN UNFAIR PROCESS BEING
DRIVEN BY SORE LOSERS AND THERE
IS NOT ONE VOTE IN THE
UNITED STATES SENATE TO IMPEACH
PRESIDENT TRUMP BASED ON THIS
PHONE CALL BECAUSE HE DID
NOTHING WRONG.
>> Sean: ADAM SCHIFF IS NOW A
NONREPUBLICAN.
ADAM SCHIFF IS NOT COMPROMISED.
HE IS NOW A FACT WITNESS IN THIS
CASE BECAUSE HIS STAFF HAD
CONTACT WITH AND ON
WHISTLE-BLOWER.
ARE YOU ABLE TO CALL ADAM SCHIF
ADAM SCHIFF, AND I ALSO WOULD
LIKE TO BE VERY INTERESTED IF
YOU CAN CALL JOE BIDEN AND
HUNTER BIDEN BECAUSE I HAPPEN TO
BELIEVE IN MY HEART --
MAY BE IT'S MY WILD IMAGINATION,
BUT IF IT WAS VICE PRESIDENT
TRUMP THAT USED TAXPAYER MONEY,
HAD A QUID PRO QUO, FIRE HIM,
YOU GET THE MONEY.
DON'T FIRE HIM, NO MONEY.
HUNTER, WITH NO EXPERIENCE, GETS
MILLIONS.
I THINK IF IT WAS VICE PRESIDENT
TRUMP AND DON JR., I THINK THE
MEDIA AND THE DEMOCRATS WOULD BE
ACTING DIFFERENTLY.
CAN YOU CALL THEM BEFORE YOUR
COMMITTEE?
>> I CAN'T CALL ADAM SCHIFF.
WE HAVE CONSTITUTIONAL
SEPARATIONS HEAR ABOUT SOMEBODY
WHO IS INVESTIGATING A CRIME TO
CALL ADAM SCHIFF POTENTIALLY AS
A WITNESS --
NO MEMBER OF CONGRESS IS ABOVE
THE LAW BUT CONGRESSMAN CAN'T
CALL SENATORS AND SENATORS CAN
CALL THE PRESIDENTS BECAUSE OF
SEPARATION OF POWER.
IN TERMS OF JOE BIDEN AND HUNTER
BIDEN, I THINK SOMEBODY
DEFINITELY NEEDS TO LOOK INTO
THIS AND IT WAS ABOUT FOREIGN
AID TO THE FOREIGN RELATIONS
COMMITTEE WOULD HAVE OVERSIGHT
SO LET ME GET BACK TO WHAT'S
GOING ON IN THE HOUSE.
AND HISTORY OF THE COUNTRY, WE
NEVER HAD THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE PARTICIPATE IN AN
IMPEACHMENT INQUIRY UNDER THE
RESOLUTION THAT THEY ARE GOING
TO PASS TOMORROW.
THE PRESIDENT'S COUNCIL CANNOT
PARTICIPATE IN THE INTEL
COMMITTEE INQUIRY SO THE
PRESIDENT HAS DENIED RIGHT TO
COUNSEL AND REPUBLICANS CAN'T
CALL WITNESSES WITHOUT SCHIFF
AGREEING SO THIS WHOLE THING IS
A SHAM.
>> Sean: DO YOU THINK --
I BELIEVE WHAT I'M HOLDING IN MY
HANDS, THIS IS A PHONY
RESOLUTION.
THIS IS FAKE NEWS.
IF THIS FAKE FAIRNESS.
I BELIEVE YOU ARE RESPONSIBLE
FOR THIS.
YOU PUT OUT YOUR PETITION, YOU
GOT 50 SIGNATURES.
THAT'S A PRETTY MAGIC NUMBER.
NOW MY QUESTION IS, MAYBE WE
SHOULD HAVE HER TWO AND SAY
UNLESS THEY DO WHAT
NEWT GINGRICH DID, WE STILL FEEL
THE SAME WAY.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> I THINK JOE CUNNINGHAM FROM
SOUTH CAROLINA COME THE
DEMOCRATIC LIVING THE FIRST
CONGRESSIONAL DISTRICT, HE SAID
HE'S GOING TO VOTE FOR THE
INQUIRY AND HERE'S WHAT I WOULD
TELL CONGRESSMAN CUNNINGHAM.
YOU ARE VOTING FOR AN INQUIRY
THAT ALLOWS THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE TO DO WITNESS
INTERVIEWS BEHIND CLOSED DOORS
AND THE PRESIDENT'S COUNSEL IS
NOT ALLOWED TO ATTEND.
THE BASIC PREMISE OF DUE PROCESS
IS TO CONFRONT YOUR WITNESSES,
THE ACCUSERS AGAINST YOU, AND A
CALL WITNESSES ON YOUR BEHALF.
NEITHER CAN BE DONE UNDER THIS
RESOLUTION.
THIS IS A CORRUPT DUE PROCESS
AND IF YOU TRY TO DO THIS TO A
DEMOCRAT, THEY WOULD BE EATING
US ALIVE COULD LET ME STRESS IS.
INTEL COMMITTEE, THE PRESIDENT'S
COUNSEL CANNOT PARTICIPATE IN
ONE OF THE CANS CANNOT CALL
WITNESS AND LESS SCHIFF AGREES.
THAT IS A JOKE AND ANY DEMOCRAT
WHO VOTES IN FOR THIS I BELIEVE
IS VOTING FOR AN UN-AMERICAN
PROCESS.
THE ONE YOU'VE BEEN AT A NUMBER
OF THE PRESIDENTS RALLIES.
ANOTHER ONE IN DALLAS HAS LIKE
35,000 PEOPLE OUTSIDE WATCHING.
OKAY.
GREATEST SHOW ON EARTH.
I DON'T KNOW IF A BAND EVEN GETS
THAT KIND OF CROWDED BUT HERE'S
MY QUESTION TO YOU.
I DO HAVE THE HONOR OF DOING
THREE HOURS OF RADIO AND I SEE
MY SOCIAL MEDIA AND I CAN TELL
YOU MY BELIEF AS EVIDENCED BY
THESE CROWDS AND THE INTENSITY,
I CAN NEVER IN MY LIFE WITNESSED
SUCH RESOLUTION AND ANGER
THAT IF DEMOCRATS DO THIS AND
IMPEACHMENT, AND THEY CAN, AND
HE'S NOT GOING TO GET CONVICTED
IN THE SETTING, I BELIEVE THE
PEOPLE WHO VOTED FOR TRUMP IN
2016 AND PROBABLY MANY OTHERS
ARE GOING TO BE WILLING TO WAIT
IN LINE A MONTH IN THE POURING
RAIN AND SLEET AND SNOW TO VOTE
FOR TRUMP AND REELECT HIM IN
2016 --
2020.
DO YOU AGREE WITH THAT?
>> THE BACKLASH IS GOING TO BE
WIDE AND DEEP BECAUSE WHAT THEY
ARE DOING A PRESIDENT TRUMP
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS UNFAIR, IT'S
SORE LOSERS CAN'T ACCEPT THE
CONSEQUENT AS OF LOSING AN
ELECTION AND THIS PROCESS, IT'S
A JOKE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS BEING TREATED
UNFAIRLY AND MOST AMERICANS ARE
GOING TO SAY SO WHEN THEY
UNDERSTAND WHAT'S HAPPENING.
>> Sean: SO THERE ARE REALLY
GOING TO PRAY HELP
PRESIDENT TRUMP GET REELECTED AT
THIS AREN'T THEY?
>> NO.